a barricade situation sends some in the
northwest valley out of their homes
for hours 8 news no reporter madison
kimbrough joins us live now near el
capitan and grand teton
with the latest and madison how's it
looking out there now
yes it's been quite the night for
residents here in the spring mountain
ranch community
as metro police received a call around 5
30 this afternoon from a woman
that said her husband was armed and
threatening to kill himself
now take a look at the video that we
shot earlier where you can really see
the extent of the team
you can see metro police and the swat
team were out in full force
the man who lives right here on
meisenheimer avenue was armed with a
rifle and handgun
at no point did he threaten his wife but
did refuse to leave his home several
residents that live in the neighborhood
were unable to get to their houses
due to the roads being blocked off
here's what one neighbor had to say
originally when it happened i'm like
okay is it a bomb is it you know
somebody that's very dangerous
i actually have my garage open too like
right before i left so
that's even more scary just to you know
somebody could have maybe ran up in the
house or
so yeah definitely definitely worrisome
now as of nine o'clock tonight the man
voluntarily gave up and surrendered his
weapons
his wife is said to be okay but the man
is suspected
to face some type of mental aid issues
and will be
assessing that as soon as possible
reporting live madison kimbrough 8
news now